vous les connaissez déjà vous les
connaissez peut-être pas encore mais une
chose est sûre c'est qu'ils ont choisi
le théâtre pour le meilleur et pour le
rire et qu'ils seront le 9 avril à la
ferme du mousseau pour un plateau
découverte jeune humoriste pour vous les
présenter puisqu'il y aura kyan khojandi
de brefs jules galibert mais aussi
d'autres talents donc pour vous les
présenter
voici un découvreur de talents justement
qui a fait ses preuves puisqu'il a lancé
jamel debbouze et qu'il vient d'être
décoré dans l'ordre des arts et des
lettres
voici donc papilles dans le kiosque
c'est d'abord une rencontre avec
virginie marson et la volonté dire fini
de se dire mais comment on peut faire
pour avoir de ces jeunes humoristes d'où
ça vient était encore dans le coup
papilles ça serait super que on
travaille autour de ça nous est venue
cette idée jb coûte super faisons un
plateau de jeunes humoristes
d'humoristes moi je je connais j'ai
suivi et j'espère bien pour eux que ce
sera les prochaines vedettes encore qui
rayonneront au niveau national donc
voilà je m'appelle kyan khojandi je suis
un grand fan de films américains comme
discale et est ce que j'aime beaucoup
chez les américains surtout les acteurs
américains c'est qu'ils pratiquent le
double et je suis chaud thé dans leurs
films voyez ce que je veux dire le
doublé chuchoter c'était mettre dans cet
exercice là le doublé chuchoter le
doublé
culotté je vous le fais je me fais la
une le fait mais enfin steven mais tu as
couché avec kimberley mais c'est ma
soeur mais tu n'as vraiment pas de
scrupules le mec fait attend trisha je
vais t'expliquer sais pas du tout ce que
tu crois expliqué ce qu'ils veulent
tu places doublés chuchoter
alors attention c'est pas les américains
qui l'ont inventé le doublé show tcd
france est un
on en a tous un droit entourage ce genre
de mec qui parle pour parler c'est pas
comment finir ses phrases avant la
faillite double roger haut il passera
pas l'hiver
ian j ai rencontré il ya deux ans sur
sur le comedy club à paris de djamel ou
moi je les fais rentrer dans la troupe
maintenant tyan n'est plus à présenter
bref marre là c'est une fille avec qui
je couche encore quelqu'un que une
rencontre une belle rencontre avec
quelqu'un ou je pense qu'il ya du talent
et non seulement je le pense c'est que
du coup il a fait reconnaître lui assez
rapidement et dans ma famille en fait
ils sont tellement bizarre que ma mère
elle m'a appelé quand 10 à cause du
dessin animé
je me suis demandée en fait qu'est ce
qu'elle pensait en se mariant avec un
vietnamien que j'allais ressortir
comment genre blonde les cheveux frisés
avec des grands grands yeux en forme de
porte
et que comme dans les mangas là j'allais
pleurer sur les côtés candy qui est
aussi une jeune femme que j'ai
rencontrée qui jouait il ya deux trois
ans au paname candy dans cette petite
salle du paname j'ai vu faire son
spectacle me l a quelque chose donc on a
commencé à travailler ensemble
je les fais rentrer aussi au comedy club
dans la firme du conditionnement à
l'époque en même temps que kian et on
continue ce travail là et aujourd'hui je
travaille sur la mise en scène de son
spectacle qui se joue en ce moment à la
cible le samedi à 19 heures voilà et
qu'on retrouve aussi le mercredi au
théâtre de dix heures bien vivace et
s'impatiente enrichir votre petit fils à
cet ebit au dessus tu dit agacé toute la
journée qu'on l'entend je vais vous dire
un truc avec son nom mais c'est pas
possible
écoutez c'est simple la semaine dernière
j'étais avec un client oui oui après son
coup de main comme ça lydia libère alors
encore julie c'est c'est tout le travail
en plus qu'une comédienne de la
compagnie qui avec sa production mastoc
à monter son spectacle qui se joue en ce
moment au théâtre de dix heures est
vraiment là encore une fois c'est un
bonheur de d'accompagner julie dans ce
travail et de pouvoir encore une fois la
promouvoir cet artiste avec toutes les
compétences qu'elle a si tu disais que
la spa ça veut dire un mot populaire
honda
s'il de droite de provinciaux dessous et
le dernier but i'm in une écriture
particulière tout une dérision de
justement et toutes les peurs qu'on a
autour de la chine
le péril jaune est pas loin et là il
vous explique avec humour
en quoi le péril jaune c'est vrai ils
vont avoir entre entre 15 et 20 minutes
moi j'animerai le plateau je vais faire
le monsieur loyal de ce plateau parce
que c'est papy qui présente les potes
sur sur cette scène là donc je pense
qu'on va avoir effectivement là du coup
quatre univers extrêmement différents
c'est une chance sur saint-quentin de
pouvoir avoir des gens de ceux de cette
teneur là c'est vrai que dans l'est dans
les administrations parfois ça prouve
être gênant ainsi devient retrouver dans
des situations difficiles ou oui un
monsieur qui lui demandait comment elle
s'appelait que les ans vita vous me
plaît oui vous aussi vous me plaît
beaucoup
et maintenant un nouveau sujet de la
rédaction ils encourent les vieilles
pierres de la commanderie des templiers
ont des choses à nous raconter
visites découvertes entre patrimoine et
art contemporain nous est proposé le
premier dimanche de chaque mois dans le
cadre du label ville d'art et d'histoire
il ya la moitié de la vie qui est
vraiment sur l'histoire et
l'architecturé des lieux
et puis dans le même temps on propose
aux gens de découvrir l'exposition
actuelle du site donc l'exposition d'art
contemporain puisqu'aujourd'hui c'est le
coeur du projet de la commanderie des
templiers
donc en ce moment c'est une exposition
de dessins ça change régulièrement et
comme ça les gens forment même revenir
plusieurs fois avec leurs amis et le
voir une exposition différente à chaque
fois sur les chemins de saint jacques de
compostelle celui emblématique fondée au
12e siècle par les moines soldats de
l'ordre du temple a connu de multiples
affectations utilisé au départ pour
l'accueil des pèlerins qui convertit en
exploitation agricole
la commanderie est restaurée est ouverte
au public dans les années 70 une
deuxième vague de restauration en 2008
et 2012
en fait aujourd'hui un centre culturel
et historique à vocation polyvalente
l'art contemporain est à l'honneur cette
année dans le bâtiment des garde qui
accueille les expositions temporaires
l'originalité de la visite à deux voix
offre ainsi au public une mise en
parallèle entre l'histoire de ce lieu de
patrimoine et l'art contemporain qui est
exposée on n'avait jamais eu de parcours
historique sur la commanderie on a
l'habitude de voir des sculptures
modernes ici des artistes des artistes
contemporains et ça nous choque pas de
le mélange des deux la chapelle derniers
témoins médiévale de la région et les
expositions sont à découvrir tous les
premiers dimanches du mois
et encore quelques dates à noter avant
votre cours de krav maga jean jacques
alingue et et tom mcclung des
proposeront leurs afro jazz le 23 mars
au prisme à elancourt tandis que francis
perrin s'illustrera dans un stylo dans
la tête toujours le 23 mars à la ferme
du manet à montigny les exceptionnels
solistes de lavilledieu quant à eux
seront le 23 mars à l'auditorium de
l'école de musique de trappes avec leur
programme
paris des dates que vous pouvez
retrouver sur internet aux adresses qui
s'affiché cette semaine sur le
www.sears.ca qui point fr vous pouvez
gagner 5 x 2 places pour mangez le si
vous voulez à la fin du mousseau à
elancourt et 5 x 2 places également pour
une vie sur mesure à l'estaminet à magny
les hameaux
alors bon spectacle à tous et à bientôt
le cachet damages